la colère des éboueurs se sent et se
voit à toulouse les poubelles et les
containers pleins laisse déborder leurs
déchets sur le trottoir
avec l'application de la loi de
transformation de la fonction publique
la métropole a annoncé à ses agents la
fin du fini-parti
débaucher une fois la collecte terminée
ce n'est donc plus possible soit les
éboueurs ont intercepté la fin du fini
parti ce qui est vraiment je pensais
même pas moi le voir un jour sans et un
par contre ils demandent l'application
de la loi à savoir la reconnaissance et
d'un taux de pénibilité pour le métier
le plus dur de la fonction publique
territoriale il y avait deux métiers qui
était considéré comme très très dur dans
la fonction publique territoriale
c'était égoutiers éboueurs ont la bonne
des égoutiers ça a été vendu au privé il
ya vingt ans il n'y a plus que les
éboueurs sont là nous demandons la
reconnaissance un taux deux entre 15 et
20% de pénibilité pour compenser le
passage aux 35 heures de travail
hebdomadaires au lieu des 25 en moyenne
avec le fini parti les éboueurs
réclament un droit de congés élargi mais
malgré ce qu'il considère comme des
efforts les négociations sont toujours
au point mort confronté depuis trois
semaines à ses poubelles qui
s'amoncellent les riverains sont quant à
eux partagés sur la raison d'être de
cette grève je peux comprendre oui
effectivement parce qu'ils ont des
travaux pénibles
bon donc ce moyen-là de se faire
entendre mais en même temps ça amène l
insalubrité ça amène peut-être des
maladies si ça continue voilà quoi après
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup de
monde qui sont pas au courant qu'il ya
une grève et qui donc ne savent pas
pourquoi des déchets sont dans la rue je
tendance à à soutenir la grève des
éboueurs parce qu'ils ont des conditions
de travail difficiles et que je pense
que leurs revendications sont très
légitimes ce mercredi après midi les
représentants des syndicats et les élus
se retrouveront à la table des
négociations
en l'absence d'accord la grève pourrait
encore se durcir